c'est la troisième fête de la violette
aujourd'hui on est à la fête de la
violette c'est la fête de la violette
alors aujourd'hui on est à la fête de la
violette c'est la grande fête de la
droite la troisième fête de la droite et
a lieu en sologne dans ce beau
département du loir-et-cher à
l'invitation de guillaume pelletier
geoffroy didier et la bradford
oui
j'apprécie énormément vraiment un
la convivialité on échange des idées
des points très divers il ya aussi un
rassemblement de personnes c'est à dire
qu'on se retrouve entre nous je pense
que c'est la réunion d'une grande
famille qui va essayer de se mobiliser
on est plus de 4000 aujourd'hui la fête
de la violette
des donneurs et nicolas sarkozy que nous
attendrons voilà avec impatience on
attend nicolas sarkozy présent des
républicains qu'on espère tous voir et
entendre parce qu'il a des choses
importantes à nous dire importante sur
la situation de la france est importante
aussi pour la reconquête de l'eau
territoire des régions au mois de
décembre
nicolas est revenue par milow est ce
assez c'est formidable c'est vrai qu'on
l'attend pour l'attendre
on n'est plus là
il
m
nous aurons beaucoup voilà il faut
comprendre
c'est aussi la chance de partager des
passions des idées à l'idée à une séance
c'est tout pour moi
selon lui ce rendez vous là l'envié